One of the simplest
if not the best ways to do a proportional system
is to have voters simply put an "X" next to their favorite party
and then you take those results from the citizens' votes
and you try to match your representatives to that as closely as possible
given the number of seats that you have in your legislative branch.
But, one of the philosophical problems that you might have with such a system
is that the citizens aren't voting for individuals in particular,
they're voting for the party in general.
And what that means is there needs to be a meeting that happens somewhere
at the party headquarters where they determine who their favorite candidates are.
And so when the monkey party gets told that they have three seats
they have already made a list of who gets the first seat, the second seat, and the third seat.
Proportional systems do have the advantage that their explicit goal is to try to match
the legislative branch of the government as closely as possible to how the citizens have voted.
STV is a bit of a proportional"ish" system.
Proportionality is not its goal; its goal is actually trying to make sure that
as many citizens as possible have local representatives that they voted for
and also to minimize the number of unhappy voters.
And as a side effect you get a roughly proportional legislature, but not exactly.